Пральні машини, холодильники та габаритні меблі.
Ця величезна зала переповнена ними.
Іноді сюди, до центру повернення Hermes у Вестфалії,
що на заході Німеччини, щодня приїжджають 100 вантажівок.
Це великі й важкі товари з інтернет-магазину OTTO, від яких відмовились клієнти.
Зазвичай йдеться про обсяги від 3 000 до 4 000 штук на день
– деревина, електричні компоненти, телевізори чи пральні машини.
Здебільшого це електроніка, яку могли пошкодити під час доставлення,
або ж вона не сподобалася клієнту.
Можливо, причина була в якості звуку. Причин дуже багато.
Деякі клієнти замовляють по 5 велосипедів або навіть диванів,
але залишають собі лише один, як це часто буває з одягом та аксесуарами.
На щастя, таке трапляється нечасто.
Але логісти тут іноді просто розводять руками.
Один клієнт хотів морозильну камеру, але помилково купив 4,
тож три довелося повернути назад. Це лише один з прикладів.
Екстраординарна ситуація. Або великі телевізори.
Клієнт може відмовитися від доставлення, тому що бачить величезний пакунок
на сходовому майданчику і розуміє, що телевізор надто великий,
а про габарити під час оформлення замовлення він не подумав.
Будь-яке повернення, незалежно від розміру або ваги, має бути розпаковане
і перевірене на наявність транспортних пошкоджень, вм'ятин і подряпин.
Чи був товар у вжитку, чи він виглядає як новий?
За словами Даніеля Райзінґера, більшість повернень можна
віднести безпосередньо до відділу продажів.
Там він перевіряє повернуті холодильники та ліжка.\
Іноді на нього та його колег чекають дуже неприємні сюрпризи.
Звісно, до нас також іноді потрапляє обладнання, яке було у вжитку, зношене зсередини.
А через транспортування іноді всередині з'являється пліснява
через залишки їжі. Потім утворюється волога, і техніка стає
повністю зіпсованою і не підлягає відновленню.
Навіть для перепродажу вона вже не в ідеальному гігієнічному стані.
Товари, які вже не можна продати, становлять тут не більше 9 відсотків.
Але кожне повернення вартує дуже дорого як у грошовому еквіваленті,
так і з точки зору клімату.
Саме так сталося зі спеціалістом з продажу меблів Home24.
Саме тому інтернет-магазин меблів відкрив шоуруми у великих містах,
таких як Берлін, щоб потенційні клієнти могли випробувати
продукцію перед замовленням. Вони можуть не лише побачити
тканинну оббивку, а й спробувати, яка вона на дотик.
Згодом багато клієнтів змінюють колір або розмір.
Мені завжди складно обирати меблі з екрана телевізора сидячи на дивані.
Я не можу уявити, які вони насправді, маючи перед очима лише картинку,
і мені хотілося б подивитися на них у тривимірному вигляді.
Бачити пропорції - дуже важливо. Тоді ви маєте краще уявлення про продукт.
Близько 7 відсотків усіх замовлень повертаються.
Це добре, каже Флоріан Ґутш. Наприклад, в індустрії онлайн-покупок
одягу цей показник перевищує 50 відсотків.
Коли йдеться про великі предмети меблів, витрати на повернення
- це лише частина проблеми.
Екологічний аспект - надважливий. Кожне повернення також
призводить до викидів вуглекислого газу. Ми не тільки повинні
перепакувати продукти, ми повинні їх забрати.
Ми маємо перемістити їх на склад. Це все фактори, які ми хочемо мінімізувати.
Магазин Home24 також намагається зменшити відсоток повернення,
пропонуючи точні описи та змістовні фотографії на сайті.
Якщо на певний товар є великий попит, власна фотостудія компанії
зробить нові або додаткові знімки протягом кількох годин.
Вони також фотографують товари, які часто повертають через те,
що колір або форма відрізняються від представлених на сайті.
Власна майстерня компанії також може відремонтувати пошкодження,
які сталися під час доставки. Тоді товари не доведеться викидати.
Мебляр Сікстен Варнкен каже, що це не лише зменшує витрати компанії.
Це також зменшує їхній вплив на навколишнє середовище.
Це може зайняти годину, дві. Іноді п'ять хвилин, залежно від того,
про що йдеться. Шафи, стільці, полиці, дивани, серванти…
Навіть всілякі прикраси. Їх привозять сюди щодня.
Деякі трошки поламані, подряпані, або десь щось відкололося.
А якщо, наприклад, подряпини або зламані деталі не вдається
ідеально відремонтувати, їх відправляють до Жозефіни Дюмде.
До магазину так званих товарів "Б-класу", або аутлету,
що знаходиться по сусідству. Таким чином, Home24 може
залучити абсолютно нову групу клієнтів.
І навряд чи магазину доведеться щось викидати.
Клієнти – це переважно пари, які з'їжджаються разом.
Співвідношення ціни та якості занадто хороше, щоб його ігнорувати.
Речі тут не зберігаються довше тижня, і у нас немає додаткового місця
для зберігання. Тому: товари треба продавати негайно.
У центрі повернення Hermes у Вестфалії демонтують пральну машину.
Майстерні, подібні до цієї, зараз поширені. Мета - зменшити кількість повернень.
Інспектори перевіряють рейтинги клієнтів і причини повернення.
Вони також аналізують причину дефектів.
Ми збираємо товари з дефектами, а потім запрошуємо постачальників,
щоб разом з нашими колегами визначити проблему.
Які дефекти виявив клієнт і як ми можемо уникнути їх у майбутньому,
щоб більше не було повернень?
Кожна десята частина відсотка, на яку зменшується кількість повернень,
економить гроші та зменшує навантаження на навколишнє середовище.
По всій Німеччині вдається уникнути кількох сотень
непотрібних поїздок на вантажівках. Щодня.